je voudrais également sorti je n'avais
pas de cette unité
j'avais marc palestinisme il fait tirer
une balle dans la tête
[Musique]
c'est bon
parce qu'on allait tout salon light à
temps
il adorait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
60 des porcs c'est que les palestiniens
citoyens d'israël et notamment tous les
jeunes se mobilisent en saut vers le thé
en soutien est ce que le riz pour les
palestiniens des territoires occupés
pour jérusalem jérusalem capitale de la
palestine à l'aller les yeux plus gros
que le ventre
netanyahu vous allez voir ce canton dit
certaines heures le beau col vento
palestinien s'est réveillé et s'est
jamais endormi on a cru qu'on allait
encore faire comment les indiens
d'amérique
et bien non on est qu'elle est
rédhibitoire
allez on au quai les ferries dans le
[Applaudissements]
port
[Musique]
il ya pas mal
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui